are you ready jazz is deftly very
intellectual in order to do it you
really have to dive into the harmony and
figure out what's going on and I think
there's a part of all of us that really
likes analyzing things it's a great
outlet for people to really be able to
express themselves and do things at a
high level
when you really nail something and get
it in the right spot and you know play
it exactly the right way it feels like
the universe's falling into place
you
in the 1950s the tech Tony ins which was
a big band were performing dances they
were performing functions and claw
sleepin who was a music director at that
time thought we should try to harness us
somehow and make it better and the
number one person the Boston scene at
that time who was leading big bands and
was known as a consummate teacher was
her palm Murray and I'm sure what he
probably said the herb is I want the
best then we can have get it going in
the spring of nineteen sixty three what
he did with the program here was to
build it from the ground up he
illuminated the essence of the students
passion and he brought a sense of
professionalism and polish
the experience for me was just one of
wonder at how he managed a rehearsal
he had a wonderful way of working with
the students so that he could push them
and get maximum effort out of them but
at the same time be congenial he had
lots of little tricks that liven up you
know your melody lines when you're
playing and I've been passing these on
to people for decades now he said a real
good example for me he was he was a kind
straight ahead down-to-earth
communicative helpful guide and made me
feel comfortable right away
the reputation that he built here for
having a great band I think it probably
attracted a lot of people it was called
the festival jazz ensemble because in
the early days they would go to various
jazz festivals he auditioned everybody
he was turning so many people away
decided to start like a feeder band the
concert jazz band was led by Everett
longstreth and his focus is really to
teach us the fundamentals the big
difference from me with the MIT people
was when I told him something I only had
to tell him once and I couldn't do it
all the time because maybe they didn't
have the technique they do it all the
time but they understood it I was always
just really blown away not only by the
caliber of the band but the caliber of
the music was always fresh it was always
knew
jamshid Sharif he was the the next one
right after her band in fact he had been
a student of herbes at Berkeley as well
as at MIT so he was essentially
handpicked by her to succeed him he was
younger and hipper and he brought a new
vibe to the band he was also a really
good writer some of the best music in
the band's library comes from jamshid
I grew up with music that included rock
and funk and R&B and soul and even
hip-hop so all of those I felt were
viable rhythmic areas that the band
could explore
in 1981 Mark Harvey joined the faculty
and he really has been a central figure
to the jazz education experience at MIT
since that time
I've had a couple classes with him and
he's a genius and he's incredibly open
to two students new ideas it was a
laboratory for composers
Jim Odell had great success with
festivals and he brought wonderful
artists to engage and work with the
students including phil woods and
terence blanchard and he also continued
having local and national jazz composers
innovative jazz composers right
expressly for the ensemble who's writing
who can I talk to about getting some
charts who can I get over here to work
with the band you know help me feed
their you know the great appetite that
the fda's students had we've been
privileged and honored to be able to
interact with some of the greatest jazz
artists on the planet
legendary saxophonist Joe Lovano has
been an artist in residence a number of
times here at MIT
we were rehearsing one of his na nets
and I had tried to as best I could do to
flee rehearse it close to the temple
that he had recorded it at and he came
in and took it at a tempo that I had
never done it with with the students and
I was a little worried and unbelievably
and he was playing with them they rose
to the occasion and played way over
their heads
and it was amazing to seen it was just
another example of when you take a great
artist and you put them with students
for a passionate and have the ability to
rise they will rise
technology MIT we are rehearsing chick
Korea's from forever it's dedicated to
her Pomeroy and the notion that he would
write a piece for MIT sent me out of
orbit we thought we would run it for you
this chick corea piece is this beautiful
amalgam asst mess of melody and harmony
and rhythmic counterpoint
it's taken a while for the whole been to
kind of dig through this this heap of
content and started and gel it together
you can think that way former politician
at that section what was to create an
illusion look at a rhythmic illusion but
that second part of the phrase like
going to back be there a son yeah
the students that perform music at MIT
and particularly jazz have such a deep
love of it that they just have to do it
it isn't a choice almost and I think MIT
is about passion it's about excellence
it's about stretching and I think any
innovation involves risk and jazz at MIT
is no exception
it's definitely been something that's
made my time at MIT much more enjoyable
this is my meditation this is my sit
down time where I just get to be in the
moment and lose myself in the music that
I get to make with the people around me
it's just you know one of the fondest
memories I have of all of MIT by far
there's nothing to stop MIT from being a
leader in the Jazz field for another 50
years hi this is chick corea I want to
congratulate all of you absolutely would
like to congratulate the MIT jazz band
and program happy birthday on 50 let's
have 50 more at least
congratulations to the festival jazz
ensemble for your 50th anniversary
you've lasted fifty years and it's only
getting better
congratulations a mighty jaws
you